Sao ngô gồn thương mề mô tạ nhà khu khỏi, tổng bị thư tổ lâm dự lệ công bố quên định của bộ chính trị về nhân sự hóa vi thư tương dự đàn quyết quốc hội.
Theo đó, bộ chính trị quyết định đồng trí độ văn trịnh, viếp bộ chính trị biết thư trương mương đàn,
viết thư đàn quyết mặt trạc tổ quốc, các bạn thị trung gương, chợ tệ quý bán trương mặt trợ quốc Việt Nam,
thôi thầm giang, bán thị thư phó mở bán, thôi thầm già bán trứ khai bán thựng tự đàn quyết.
Thôi dự chức bý thư đàn quyền mặt trợ quốc, các bạn thị trung gương,
giệp kế hành hông trong hành người hành hình phòng trình hành nha.
Điều độ phân công, trị định tham gia bán trứ khai bán thương bộ đàn quyết,
và giữ trước, phó vi thư thường trực đàn quyết hốt hội, giệp kế hành hông trong hành người hành hình phòng trình hành nha.
Chúc mừng tân, phó vi thư thường trực đàn quyết quốc hội,
tổng bị thư tổ lâm mong muốn trên công việc công tác mới,
đồng chiế độ phân chiến tiếp tục vàng kết thống nhất với các đồng chi trong đàn quyết quốc hội.
Vũ khội, vì bán thường bộ Quốc hội, lãnh đạo Quốc hội màn thành các nhiệm vụ của mình,
tổ chức chiến khai thực hiện tốt các trường trương đường lối chính xác của đàn,
các quyết xác của Quốc hội trong thời gian tới.
Các đồng chiế trong đàn quyết quốc hội, vì bán thường bộ Quốc hội, tiếp tục duy trị chuyển thống vàng kết thống nhất,
tạo thêm rất mạnh, cùng khối hợp đều màn thành đốt nghiệm vụ.
Tân phó biết thương trực đàn quyết quốc hội đổ văn chiến, bệnh ở nềm xúc đồng,
vinh dự khi đặc bộ chính trị tinh tưởng giá trọng trách mới,
hàng định sẽ không gần học tập tu dữ dữ dành định phẩm trách đặc đức,
đối mới phương pháp công tác, phát viーテng thành đoàn kết tận truyết hết lòng, hết sức phục hộ.
Bây tỏ mâm muốn tiếp tục nhận được sự trị đạo quan tâm bộ bộ chính trị, bán lý thơ.
Tổng bị thư tốt lâm, sự tiết quốc hội trần thình bán,
sự hội trợ của hợp trách trễ của bán trước hành bán từ buộc đàn quyết quốc hội,
vì bán từ buộc hội hội hội đông dân tộc,
các quyết bán của khối hội và tỏng thể cánh bộ,
đàn viên công trước viên trước người lóng đậu các cơ quan quốc hội,
đều hành thành đốt trọng trách được ra.